you're one of about five people that
have been invited around my house i'm a
very sort of private person apart from
like you know workman and postman um and
uh it makes me feel special yeah
that alan carr a postman rounded
there's not even any water here can i
have a drink of water
unfortunately oh you've got some well no
brilliant yeah i bought this myself you
have to buy your own out of bbc that's a
quid you want that's a pound i want from
you
that's a pound
okay let's do an interview
okay ricky the golden globe statue is
round name three other things that
around the earth
um my balls
[Applause]
how long is your i'm not asking how long
is
i'm not at seven inches all right well
listen
that tie is pointing that's what ties do
that's what they're for is it really
yeah that's what i thought necklaces do
that to cleavage yeah yeah the necklaces
are like here's my boobies and ties are
like yeah guess what this is yeah but
but according to this morris boobies are
meant to be your ass cheeks that's what
you're saying is going right my ass
cheeks right but why why why would you
want one with ass cheeks there
that's odd
well no it's to represent the artist
yeah but why that we know where the arse
is it's a completely different direction
stop doing that with your finger
how much time you spin in london i know
you got a house here how much time do
you spend here how much time you spend
in london well between the two probably
a bit more in london but you know
yeah i like i'd like to come as often as
i can aren't the taxes bloody awful in
london
um in england isn't it just crazy well
i'm like you i like paying tax because
it's giving something back
listen i'm with you
with this god thing lizard whip you know
as in uh yes
i mean but there's a bit of you thinks
you know what if it is true what do you
do when you meet god oh forgive me will
he yeah and it's his fault why did he
make me an atheist
because i would love to try stand up i'd
love to do something i think you'd be
good i think it'd be good you say that
but when i try and write a joke i get i
get the opening bit i said that's a
funny idea madonna's got divorced and
then i think
yeah where's my writer you know i don't
well yeah i don't know
right we'll all do this right watch this
right all right and we got a camera
called ass or elbow yeah if you want um
hold on look so okay i'll just take a
picture okay when you sort of
manipulate it and sort of crop it just
right
look at that
right that way yeah
name three tom hanks movies
toy story one two and
oh three no funny business there you go
not on this show
oh no it's a joke
that's a joke
what are you wearing
you're most proud of on yourself
um
it's probably um
[Music]
my second penis
no um
wow
uh every time you're on the program i
try to do this and it's always comes out
very clumsy let me try it one more time
possibly
the best television show ever
what do you think
possibly what do you mean
i'm going to interview you yeah so are
you comfortable then me on top right
right
[Applause]
you've lost a lot of weight thank you
how have you done it tell me you think
what steroids and aids
i'm gonna ask you how are the twins
oh yeah
right let me explain
um it has twins yeah
i don't now this is this is the thing i
did
i did an interview um a couple of years
ago one of those you know little
celebrity bits oh it's embarrassing
saying that word isn't it um
and it was something like um my london
and it was all like really fluffy
questions like who would you want to be
um stuck in a lift with
my mate glenn he's got a tool box and
you know
i wasn't i wasn't playing and
[Music]
if your flat was on fire and you could
only say three things what would it be
oh yeah so i went oh my cat um my
salamander
i said three she went yeah i went one of
the twins
[Music]
and this policeman comes out with a
mirror on the end of a stick and he
looks under the van like that and as
he's doing it his helmet falls off
and
20 cigarettes fell out
and the the copper looked at bob and
sort of went he went i bet you've always
wondered what we kept under our helmets
and bob went i knew it wasn't [ __ ]
brains
how do you signal to a partner that you
want to have sex unbelievable
unbelievable
like an insect
uh but when you come to the united
states uh is it are you nervous about
traveling these days for example well
i'd say with the first time um i was a
bit apprehensive coming to the states
this time a couple of reasons really the
first one is i mean obviously since the
war in iraq um it's not good to be in
america with a french name oh um but uh
i am uh i have got french blood
i don't like them either though i just
want to make
what have you named your private parts
um
pamela okay ricky name three curse words
you're allowed to say on tv
darn um cockrell
dick cheney
[Laughter]
maybe just maybe just have less
character or stop eating
what's the point in living longer if
you're sober
especially especially these days i want
to be drunk all the time
i mean you've always work together do
you ever go on holiday together
can you imagine that
oh it would be horrible just think of
the pictures me looking pretty cool and
sort of
and
tanned
thing
naked he looks like one of those baby
fish you can actually see through his
body
it's a fantastic picture think of that
running at you a thousand years ago
that's so threatening with the bubbles
ricky named three things you can cover
with chocolate
a cake yourself someone else
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's fantastic can we get a shower
it seems like you joke about this but
you're running you're you're getting in
shape for uh
the globes right well no i i arrived
believe it or not i work out nearly
every day i work out about five and i do
it sort of you know 20 minutes 30
minutes just so i can then go and eat
pizza and drink beer it's like a reward
as i'm running i'm thinking that's one
beer
that's two beers you know what i mean
okay okay thanks very much doctor sorry
[Applause]
do you mind if i masturbate
[Applause]